[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
hoy vamos a hablar de los beneficios
para nuestra salud de la meditación y no
solo nuestra salud mental sino también
las dolencias físicas Es que la
meditación Podría tener un impacto muy
positivo muchas enfermedades por ejemplo
las intestinales y para hablar de todo
esto está con nosotros el doctor Oscar
Franco Él es director del departamento
de salud pública de la Universidad de
utrac Gracias doctor Franco por estar
con nosotros como siempre en nuestro
espacio de salud en directo América de
Francia 24 Es que la meditación es una
práctica ancestral que desde hace ya
décadas muchas comunidades lo han estado
practicando y que cada vez está más de
moda Por así decirlo para tratar muchas
enfermedades como la ansiedad el estrés
o también el insomnio el pregunto a
usted Cuáles son los beneficios de la
meditación para nuestra salud mental
Sí en primer lugar yo creo que hacer
énfasis en que la Salud Mental y la
salud física están muy interrelacionadas
y no funcionan de manera separada Y
hasta ahora yo creo que hemos hablado
mucho acerca de la salud física como
algo que ocurre independiente lo que eso
ocurrió en de nuestra mente la
meditación ha sido una de las
herramientas que se ha utilizado durante
siglos para poder mejorar la Salud
Mental o para tratar la Salud Mental
dentro del punto de vista de la
evidencia y de la ciencia la evidencia y
la investigación que se ha hecho con la
meditación está apareciendo Hasta ahora
se está haciendo cada vez más robusta y
sugiere que se podría utilizar como una
alternativa o algo complementario para
poder manejar trastornos de ansiedad
problemas de sueño pero en general Más
allá de lo que se sufra o no se sufra es
de mantener la Salud Mental y en eso la
meditación podría jugar un papel doctor
y le preguntó Cómo funciona la
meditación en la que el manejo de la
respiración es imprescindible en sistema
nervioso
no solamente en el sistema nervioso lo
que se ha visto Es que la meditación el
la práctica de la respiración también de
sacar un momento para poder yo creo que
dar un descanso a la mente o dar una
forma diferente de aplicación mental
ayuda también por ejemplo a sistema
cardiometabólico Entonces se ha
relacionado con diferentes niveles de
presión arterial o con diferentes
respuestas en nuestro sistema nervioso a
las situaciones de estrés etcétera
entonces podría ayudar dentro de
diferentes perspectivas sin embargo aún
la evidencia se está construyendo cada
vez vemos nueva nuevas investigaciones
que están evaluando si la meditación
tiene un efecto y por ahora lo que
estamos viendo Es que esa evidencia está
cada vez aún más creciendo hablando
también de evidencia doctor un estudio
reciente publicado en el British Medical
journal apuntan que es la meditación
profunda a un largo plazo podría influir
en nuestra salud intestinal a través del
eje microbiota también el intestino y el
cerebro de qué se trata como hemos
hablado otras veces también y que
nuestras emociones tienen mucho que ver
con nuestro sistema digestivo
Sí hablamos del del eje intestino y
Cerebro dentro del punto de vista
científico pero culturalmente yo creo
que muchas veces cuando no estamos
cuando estamos estresados o asustados o
incluso Cuando sentimos enamoramiento se
siente algo en el estómago decimos que
se sentimos algo en el estómago hay una
relación estrecha entre el cerebro y el
y el intestino este estudio fue hecho en
el 56 monjes tibetanos entonces son unas
personas que tienen una práctica de
meditación de mucho más consolidada de
mucho más tiempo con mejor práctica
demuestran un extremo lo que la los
beneficios de la meditación que puede
incluir el cambio del microbioma en el
en nuestro sistema gastrointestinal Pero
también mejorías en el sistema
cardiometabólico y la presión arterial y
ya hay que mirar cómo podría ayudar a
las personas que no son monjes tibetanos
que no tienen una meditación profunda
pero que gradualmente pueden ir
incorporando la meditación en su vida
diaria
doctor como siempre Muchísimas gracias
por su tiempo por estar con nosotros en
ese espacio de salud de France 24
Lamentablemente se nos agotó para seguir
hablando de ese tema tan apasionante
para algunos como es la meditación y sus
beneficios doctor Muchísimas gracias
gracias
[Música]